[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing the harry
potter world post
deathly hallows and what came of
hagrid's brother
group hagrid discovers grop in 1995
when along with olimp maxime he travels
to the giant colony on
dumbledore's orders dumbledore knew that
a war was brewing with voldemort and the
death eaters
and he wanted the giants on his side who
better descend
than hogwarts lovable half-giant
groundskeeper however while hagrid was
there on business
one giant in particular stuck out to him
for you see
this giant though larger than hagrid
wasn't quite as giant
as the other giants after doing some
inquiring and after spending three days
at the giants camp
hagrid discovered that this was in fact
his half-brother group
the pair shared a mother a giantess by
the name afrid walther
the same mother that had abandoned
hagrid in his father at a young age
while there hagrid also made the
decision to bring group with him
back to hogwarts you see because of
grope's small
16-foot stature he was bullied by the
other giants
and hagrid who didn't want to see his
own blood suffer felt that he would be
able to improve grope's life
and subsequently brought him back to the
magical school knowing
that he likely wouldn't be able to keep
grope in plain sight
hagrid kept grew up in a forbidden
forest for months teaching him manners
and pieces of english
though hagrid's attempts at
domesticating group were largely futile
hagrid cared for him very much and it's
a good thing that he was around
because he was actually the reason that
harry and hermione were able to survive
their encounter with the centaurs
when harry and hermione trick umbridge
into going to the forbidden forest
she ends up being taken away by centaurs
but what's excluded from the film is
that the remaining centaurs
actually turn on harry and hermione this
is when grop steps in
and saves the day but corp's assistance
didn't end there
in fact group also had a part to play in
the battle of hogwarts
at the same time group came lumbering
around the side of the castle
and yelled haggar his cries were
answered by roars from voldemort's
giants
they ran it gwarp like bull elephants
making the earth quake
during the battle grapp tapped into a
side of himself that was previously
unseen
an angrier more serious side but
bearing all of this in mind what
happened to the lovable undersized giant
after the war after the events of the
deathly hallows
the first thing worth mentioning is that
gorp did in fact survive the battle of
hogwarts
and immediately after their victory
could be seen celebrating and laughing
while students threw food into his mouth
other than not being listed as a
casualty in the battle
there's no definitive canon answer as to
what happened to gorp
but i do have a fairly conservative
theory you see
after umbridge had been sacked at
hogwarts dumbledore and hagrid thought
it would be best to send group to live
in a cave in the mountains near
hogsmeade
as it turns out grope enjoyed the cave
quite a lot
and much preferred it to the forest
where he lived previously
though group merged from his mountain
cave to fight in the battle of hogwarts
i think the cave was actually a great
home for gwarp and that he simply
returned to live there
after the battle by this stage grope had
developed considerably from when hagrid
first found him and even began to show
an understanding of human emotions
like happiness and joy given that hagrid
stayed on its games keeper
i think that group would have simply
lived out his days traveling between
hogwarts school
and the mountains of hogsmeade what do
you guys think let me know in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
you